in an era marked by heated claims of
media bias journalists need to ensure
that news coverage is independent and
impartial education the field I know
best is one where it should be easy to
meet this bar to see where things stand
to colleagues and I analyzed major media
news coverage of federal education in
2009 and 2017 in 2017 Republicans
controlled the federal government and
proposed major new reforms back you know
nine the same was true of Democrats to
2017 news stories on Republican
proposals featured a negative slant
nearly half the time on the other hand
in oh nine coverage of Obama's proposals
tilt the negative less than five percent
of the time this kind of thing might fly
on the editorial pages but unless one
thinks that Democrats have a monopoly on
educational wisdom such reporting marks
and abject professional failure and if
journalists can't even report and
partially on education it's scary to
contemplate how they approach more
polarizing questions do you think major
media coverage is biased towards one
political party let us know in your
comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI